we've chronicled the story of former
silverado skyhawk drew robinson's return
to las vegas
here in southern nevada where robinson
rose to the top and sunk to the very
bottom
29 year old professional baseball player
survived a suicide attempt
and a heroic story to tell now this
weekend drew robinson took the field
13 months after he tried to take his own
life the silverado
high school grad shaking the sports
world with his candor and courage he is
now a global advocate for mental health
and suicide prevention
and a beacon of perseverance seems
surreal that a baseball player with one
eye
and a bullet wound could be getting hits
in aaa baseball but clearly
this las vegas mastered the art of
beating the odds
it's like a movie scene for sure i just
if i could have sat down and tried to
write something out this is exactly how
it would be
it's just so meaningful to my family and
i and all the people that supported me
my friends
the doctors that put me back together
were in attendance so
being able to come home and just get
that first
those first reps in front of everybody
was
it was just powerful and it was
something again like i i took things for
granted before and i was trying to play
a cool guy but
i finally let some emotions just
overtake me
all right now robinson is one guy
everybody is cheering for a story that
could have as drew says probably would
have ended his life in tragedy but now
inspiration and perseverance hey it's
great to see local athletes making big